baraton cagna expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université d'exeter
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soit bonsoir bar à tapas le kenya
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france ces derniers jours le nombre de
cas positifs de décès et
d'hospitalisations a augmenté de plus de
20% au royaume-uni
des chercheurs alerte désormais c'est le
début d'une troisième vague selon vous
oui j'ose espérer que ce n'est pas le
cas mais il faut être très prudent
oui le problème et ce variant plus
contaminant oh oui le move le jeu si
nous levant les restrictions si nous ne
relançons les interactions avec d'autres
personnes
la réapparition et où de folles de
restauration à l'intérieur alors les
contaminations ils vont repartir à la
hausse et pour les personnes non
vaccinées ce sur un problème
alors c'est vrai qu'on s'y attendait pas
nécessairement parce que le royaume uni
était un vrai exemple pour le reste des
européens
comment vous vous expliquer que malgré
la vaccination le variant indien semble
plus fort les variants apparaissent
n'importe où et invariants comptage il
c'est un vrai problème
le royaume-uni est en avance en matière
de vaccination mais pollue tout le monde
n'a pas été complètement vaccinés oui et
une variance circule beaucoup dans
certaines régions et il est plus
contagieux pour les personnes qui ne
sont pas pleinement vacciner notamment
pour les personnes les plus jeunes c'est
ce qui pose problème c'est vraiment le
casse-tête la clé peut-être du problème
c'est aussi les
pas centre les deux doses on rappelle
que ça a été augmentée au royaume uni
pour pouvoir vacciner davantage de monde
ça devienne mauvaise décision
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus souhaitable de
garder autant d' espaces entre les deux
doses non je ne pense pas que le
problème c'est l'écart entre la première
et la seconde touche où est le problème
c'est ce variant qui est plus contagieux
il est donc plus facile d'être de tomber
malade
le deuxième problème c'est la pression
politique calme ou deux de tous les
horizons de lever les restrictions le
plus rapidement possible à partir du 21
juin et le casse tête c'est que tout n'a
pas été vaccinés donc nous maîtrisons la
situation si et seulement si nous
continuons à bâtir et autant de
personnes que possible même avec une
simple première dose et il faut
maintenir dans le même temps des
restrictions au delà du 21 juin
cela sera dans l'intérêt de la nation
on lit souvent dans la presse
qu'astrazeneca qui représente on le
rappelle une grande partie de la
vaccination au royaume uni affiche une
efficacité modérée 1 face aux variants
un bien est ce que c'est là aussi que le
bât blesse tout de même non je ne pense
pas qu'il faut s'inquiéter de
l'efficacité et astrazeneca contre les
variants général le vaccin protège le
vaccin est vite les hospitalisations
notamment en unité de soins intensifs et
les décès donc même si l'on n'est pas
totalement protégé en tout cas ne finira
pas à l'hôpital dès que cela est
toujours le cas
le secret
c'est de vacciner autant de personnes
que possible de baisser le niveau des
circulations dans les communautés et
cela rend la communauté dans son
ensemble plus sec plus sécurisée quel
que soit le vaccin utilisé en tant que
l'épidémiologiste est-ce que vous
préconise riez une remise en cause du
déconfinement à on rappelle que le point
d'orgue doit avoir lieu d'ici quelques
jours d'ici quelques petites semaines le
21 juin au royaume uni sauf que oui oui
tout à fait et les raisons sont les
suivantes
tout d'abord nous sommes face à un
variant plus quant à l'union il est donc
plus facile de se retrouver infectés si
beaucoup de personnes sont contaminées
alors ces personnes jeunes finiront à
l'hôpital en partie et certaines
personnes mourront même il est donc
important d'adopter la stratégie
suivante à partir d'aujourd'hui aussi
rapidement que possible
il faut développer il faut enfin deux
axes mais aussi rapidement que possible
et si possible 24 heures sur 24 est
votre poste édite et la première
injection une certaine mesure de
protection s'installe donc cela est une
bonne chose pour la population et on
peut commencer à partir de ce moment-là
a levé les restrictions dans un cadre
sécuritaire bien plus avantageux contre
le variant indien ou toutes autres
nouveaux variants qui apparaîtra à
l'avenir merci bar à tapas en khâgne un
expert en maladies infectieuses à
l'université d'exeter d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france